This copying overhead that we're talking about
in this client server interaction in RPC
call is serious concern in RPC design.
Why? Because this copying happens every time you
have a call return between the client and the server. And so if there is
a place where we want to focus on shaving overheads, it'll be on avoiding
copying multiple times between the client and the server
in order to make the RPC calls efficient. And
if you go back to this analogy of a
procedure call, the nice thing about this is that this,
the arguments are set up in the stack. And
and that might involve some data movement, but there is
not kernel involvement in the data movement. And that's
what we would like to be able to accomplish in
the RPC world as well. And, in fact let's analyze how many times copying
happens in the RPC system. Recall that in a RPC system the kernel has
no idea of the syntax and semantics of the arguments that are passed between
the client and the server. But yet, the kernel has to be the intermediary in
arranging the rendezvous between the client and the server.
And therefore what happens in the RPC system is that
when a client makes a call, there's an entity,
that is called the client stub. And what the client
stub is going to do is, the client's thinking
that it's making a normal procedure call, but it is
a remote procedure call. And the client stub knows
that. And what it does is it takes the arguments
that is in the client call, which is living
on the stack of the client, and makes an RPC
packet out of it. This RPC packet is essentially
serializing the data structures that are being passed as arguments
by the client into a sequence of bytes. It's
sort of like herding cats into an enclosed space. So
that's what is happening by the client stack taking the
arguments that are on the stack of the client and
creating a packet of contiguous bytes, which is
the RPC message. Because that is the only
way the client can actually communicate this information
to the kernel. So this is the first copy
that's happening from the client stack into creating
the RPC message is the first copy that's
happening. Even before, the kernel is involved in
this client server interchange. The next thing that happens,
the client traps into the kernel and the kernel says
well, you know there is a message, which is the
RPC message that has to be communicated to the server.
And that's sitting in the user address space. I better
copy it into my kernel buffer so that's a second
copy that's happening. From the address piece of the client
is the RPC message is copied into the kernel buffer.
So that's the second copy. Next the kernel schedules the
server in the server domain because the server
has to execute this procedure. So once that server
has been scheduled the kernel copies the buffer. It,
it, it has all the arguments packaged in, into
the server domain. So that it the third copy
that's happening. So this, so we went from the
client stack to the RPC message first copy. From
the RPC message to the kernel buffer, second copy.
And now the kernel buffer is passed out to
the service domain, that's a third copy. But unfortunately
even though we've reached the address space of the
server, the server procedure cannot access this because from
the point of view of the procedure call semantics,
the client of the server think that they are
just doing procedure call. So the server procedure is
expecting all of the arguments in the original form on
the stack of the server, and that's where the server stub comes in. So what the
server stub is, just like the client stub, the server stub is a piece of code
that is part of the RPC infrastructure that
understands the syntax and semantics of the client
server communication for this particular RPC call. And
therefore it can take this information that has
now been passed into the server's address space by the kernel and structure it
into the set of actual parameters that
the procedure, the server procedure is expecting.
So this, from the server domain, wherever the kernel put it, into the stack
of the server for the server procedure
to execute that procedure, that's the fourth copy.
So you can see that just going from
the client to the server there are four copies
involved. These two copies are at the user level.
And these two copies are what the kernel is
doing in order to protect itself and the
address spaces from one another by buffering the address
space contents into a kernel buffer, and passing that
to the server domain before the server domain can
start using it in the form of actual parameters
on the stack. So at this point, the server can
start executing, the server procedure can start executing, do its
job. And when it is done, it has to do
exactly the same thing in order to pass the
results back to the client. So it is going to
go through four copies except that we're going to reverse
it. We're going to start from the server stack and
go all the way down to getting the information to
the client stack in order for that exchange to happen.
So, in other words, with the client server RPC call
on the same machine with the kernel involvement in this process,
there's going to be four copies each way. Going from
the client to the server, there's four copies. Going from
the server back to the client, there's going to be
four copies. Two copies are happening in the user space and
two copies are happening in the kernel space. Are orchestrated by
the kernel, and two copies orchestrated on the user level. Now
as you can see this is a huge, huge overhead compared
to a simple procedure call that I showed you early on.